well I don't want to give the impression
that all I do is complain about
representation when it's done badly so
what do I like okay folks so it is time
for lgbtq+ representation film film
video I'm so pompous now I make films no
I don't so well I well I change out and
remind everybody that the reason I talk
about these kinds of things aside from
the fact that they should just be talked
about I am part of the lgbtq+ community
I am I'm gender-fluid which usually puts
me either in the queue under queer or T
under trans depending on how you view
the existence of somebody like me I
don't get really hung up about it I'm
part of this community I'm safe I'm feel
confident saying that so my original
plan this month was to do a rather long
in work video on bisexual representation
and erasure
unfortunately I I really I have somebody
who I really want to have on for that
and I haven't been able to get the
scheduling worked out yet so that's
gonna happen at a later month I don't
know when yet it will definitely happen
but just just not quite yet so for now I
think I wanted to just do my own sort of
personal top ten of films that heavily
focus on or are primarily about lgbtq+
characters and stories and this was
actually harder for me to put together
than you might think because I'm
actually I'm not a great person to get
recommendations from for lgbtq+
entertainment because a lot of it when
it's truly about that as opposed to just
a side character happens to be LGBTQ
plus it is it's usually in a story that
either fits into real life you know
realistic style drama or romance and I'm
not I don't naturally gravitate towards
either one I can enjoy drama films I can
enjoy romantic
films but that's not that's not my genre
wheelhouse that's not where I naturally
kind of want to spend my time so there's
whole swathes of quote-unquote you know
queer films that I haven't seen and
don't really want to either but this is
my list of ten that I do like so um
there were some that were in contention
that I'll mention briefly that I decided
to not include because there are enough
sort of kind of problematic elements to
them that's things like in an out rent
The Birdcage and I also made the
decision to leave off the rocky or a
picture show not because it wouldn't
deserve a place on this list but because
I already devoted an entire video
talking about why I think that thing is
so awesome so you know if you want to
hear me ramble on about that you can
check you can already see that somewhere
else so that said let's get into it we
will start with number 10 but I'm a
cheerleader so this one it took me a
little while to sort of get fully on
board with because on the surface it has
some of the elements that kind of put
some of the other ones that I mentioned
earlier off the list you know kind of
like that's a bit stereotypical that's a
bit cliche but the thing is it's not
just that it's a comedy it's very much a
heightened and hyper real comedy it is
presenting a reality that is made very
clear and is stylized in such a way that
you would not mistake this for the
reality in which we exist so heightening
it just that much at least for me makes
the slightly stereotypical elements a
little bit easier to swallow if you've
never heard of this film it stars
natasha Lyonne as a young girl a high
schooler a cheerleader you know that
which is the stereotypical ideal young
teenage girl who has been sent to what
is basically a gay rehabilitation camp
because her friends believe she's a
lesbian even though she herself claims
very vehemently that she is not and then
so it becomes both a simultaneously a
parody of the way society view
and tries to cure gay people as well as
a story about her own self-discovery and
despite as I said some some humor
because it's from the late 90s so some
of the humor hasn't aged great but I
still think it's hard is absolutely in
the right place and I think it holds
together a better than a lot of 90s
comedies so I I do I do quite enjoy that
number 9 Heavenly Creatures
so this is I feel like in many ways kind
of the Forgotten Peter Jackson film
because it kind of bridged the gap
between the two phases of his career
it's not quite as insane as his early
work like brain-dead or that alive
depending on where you live or meet the
Feebles or bad taste but it also hasn't
gone in like to the to the epic grand
sweep of things like Lord of the Rings
or his version of King Kong and it's
kind of at the transitional film between
those two but it's really good and in
fascinatingly it is based off a true
story that actually happened so and
bonus it's also Kate Winslet's like big
breakout role um but you know prior to
Titanic so it's about two young women
who it's a period piece I forget when
it's set but it's two young women who
meet each other become infatuated
together and in the way that they kind
of for lack of a better term heighten
each other's feelings and perceptions
and experience and sort of their the way
they perceive the world gets a little
weird and they end up doing something
really horrible and it is kind of sweet
and then gradually become something a
little bit more sinister it is surreal
at points it is beautiful as well acted
it's it's a hard film to try and
describe but if you've never seen it
it's worth seeking out it's it's one of
those films that I can't promise you'll
enjoy
but you'll remember it number eight
camp this is the one on the list that
probably has the most tenuous claim on
being an lgbtq+ movie because it's not
really about that sort of life or
experience it it has an ensemble cast it
has a lot of lgbtq+ characters um but it
it's hard to say that it is strictly
speaking about that but what it is is it
is set at a theater camp for sort of
high school age basically theater nerds
you know to do plays and and sing and do
all that kind of stuff and as a result
there are a lot of gay male characters
there is a character who seems to be in
the early sort of discovery points of
coming to terms of himself as trans
there's a character who maybe is kind of
questioning although later it's like is
this person just like a people pleaser
and possibly a narcissist
so is that genuine we don't know which
like sounds super pop problematic but
like I kind of related to what was going
on there so like I feel like it did
something right and these characters are
they you know there's never a ton of
like drama around the fact that these
characters are gay
the counselors know they're they're
teachers they're directors they know so
they just kind of get to be there but
not quite and that happens to be gay way
it doesn't at times feel like a
celebration of that side of them so I
and and like it's a movie I was always
going to enjoy because yeah I was a
theater kid so I can watch and go yeah I
remember people like you and you and
directors like that and you know
teachers who are like this counselor and
and things like that so I it just
connects to me really well and yeah it's
gonna it's got a lot of fur lack of a
better term gay stuff going on in it
there's show tunes and drag queens and
just it's just sweet I just like it
numbers
seven milk now I'm I for me I have mixed
feelings about Sean Penn and if you're
like me that may be something that may
feel a little bit I don't know about
this and if that is hard for you like I
maybe seek out one of the documentaries
about Harvey Milk because those there's
some very good ones of those as well but
I do think Sean Penn's performance as
Harvey Milk is really fantastic and he
does great work capturing you know sort
of the the essence of the man as much as
I I have come to understand what it was
because he has that sort of quiet
unassuming strength to him he's not he
doesn't come across as strong because
he's intimidated empathy even his anger
comes from a place of empathy and
wanting to lift people up and it's it's
a remarkable man and life and story that
and and I'm just like super picky on
biopics I rarely like feel more than
yeah that was fine with them so yeah I
actually I quite enjoyed this number six
well you know it had to be on here
somewhere Brokeback Mountain and what I
liked about this store and what I liked
about it at the time and what I still
like about it is structurally it doesn't
feel substantively different from how
you would tell us a straight
relationship in terms of the way these
people behave and the way that they are
shot and the width of the story
structure and when I say that piece some
people if you haven't already seen the
movie which I think most people have at
this point but like that might make some
people nervous unlike so it's not like a
proper you know gay male love story if
it could have just been straight people
and it wouldn't change but that's not
quite what I mean like the story you the
story is impacted by the fact that
they're gay but just
the film is never trying to be a gay
film it is simply trying to be a love
story between two people and in terms of
presentation feel style camerawork
pacing all of that and that would have
been the same even with a straight
couple
but narrative Lee it does also integrate
you know the reality of two men falling
in love very well and the performances
are amazing and I'm sorry there is I
don't get hot under the collar for a lot
of make-out sessions in film it doesn't
happen often but Heath Ledger and Jake
Gyllenhaal like watching to tear each
others clothes off you could see it in
their face when they like sort of duck
in between these two buildings in this
alley for a hot second like who okay and
it's it's just a good movie number five
another movie that most people probably
expected to be on this list somewhere
boys don't cry
this one this one's kind of fascinating
for me because I think it was 99 this
came out and it still holds up amazingly
well a lot of stuff from that time frame
especially you know issue movies don't
hold up especially well but this really
does Hilary Swank's performance is
absolutely phenomenal she captures this
cockiness to this young I'm gonna say
young man you know he he did he never he
didn't live long enough to properly
transition but I'm still gonna call him
a young man and she gets the swagger she
gets the that feeling that comes with
youth of yeah this is maybe the
is risky but I'm young and I can take on
the world which of course makes the
story ultimately all the more tragic and
jarring Li so at times if you don't I
mean I suppose spoilers but like again I
feel like this movie is really well
known even if you haven't seen it
besides isn't it like a meme at this
point that Hilary Swank dies in a lot of
movies she's not quite as Sean beans
level but I feel like she's up there and
you know I I think that the the harsh
turn that it takes it is jarring in a
way that is effective it doesn't feel
like a massive tonal gear shift that
brings the thing to a halt it just feels
like oh god that's how quickly
everything can go wrong Oh God and it's
powerful next up number four Carol this
one I saw relatively recently and I saw
what my partner Liz and that was a
really good way to see it I mean yeah
I'll just say it I've never I'm a bit of
a crush on Kate Blanchet yeah I'll just
cop to that and the dynamic and the
building of the relationship between
these two women as at a time when this
sort of thing was I mean frowned upon
doesn't do it justice it was illegal
like actively prosecuted illegal in most
places and it was genuinely dangerous
for these two women to fall in love and
yet they do and but they fell in love
during a time and in a world that wasn't
gonna let that happen and there's
something about that because you really
do get the sense that had had the world
not encroached there was really
something here between these two and the
chemistry between them is
it is sweetly paced very gorgeously shot
and it has almost kind of an ethereal
quality at times that I really greatly
appreciate and I expected when I first
saw it that I was gonna like this movie
I didn't know I was gonna like it as
much as I did and I like I like it a lot
all right so we're getting up into the
top three and pretty much everything up
to this point has fallen more or less
into the standard drama romance movies
like all the films I mentioned up to
this point were movies that basically
somebody had to talk me into watching
they weren't things that I naturally
gravitated towards these last three were
movies that like I actively saw it out
I'm like I wanna see that so the first
of these three professor Marston and the
Wonder women so not only do we get a
genuinely great film about a genuinely
fascinating group of people but we get
an amazing relationship between two
women and what is probably the most
functional polyamorous relationship that
you'll find on film so far that's
anything more than in passing it's yeah
it's nice so if you hadn't heard of this
one the it's it's about the guy who
invented who created the character of
Wonder Woman and his wife and their
shared girlfriend and it's about them
meeting it's about the relationship
developing it's about the fascination
that he has with both of them it is
about the development of the feelings
these two women have for each other it
is about an exploration of kink and a
bondage and of submission and domination
and of loving different people in
different ways but equally as strongly
it is
it's a really great movie if you haven't
seen it it's it's yeah I don't know what
else to say um I
I was super excited when I heard was
being made and I was not this point of
what I saw it next one these last two I
would I kept going back and forth on
these what was gonna take the top spot
because it really could have gone either
way but first up number two the
handmaiden no not The Handmaid's Tale
this isn't the Hulu series
this is a Korean film from the director
behind old boy and Lady vengeance and
and thirst he this is a retelling of of
an existing story fingersmith I can't
remember what it what the the original
ones called but it's in it's an
elaborate con movie where a man has a
female partner that he is sending in to
get close to a wealthy woman so that
they can try and find a way to build her
out of her money and the reason this
movie is to make the list is the
connection between those two women that
is forged and you know that there's very
clearly very intense emotions there but
are they mutual do they both feel them
there's only one of them feel them it's
one of them playing the other is are
these emotions going to override what
the con was supposed to be and all these
sorts of things going on and it is so
good it is it is very adult and and as
you would expect if you know any of the
work of this director very weird at
times but it is fascinating and it is so
engaged it is riveting that is what this
film is it is riveting from start to
finish and it is even if you know like
the source material the way that it
works is
through this story and presents some of
this stuff you've not seen other things
like this so I don't want to say
anything more about it because just to
spoil this thing would be would be a
crime so yeah I'll move on from that one
to my number one spot this is one that I
had been meaning to see for a long long
time and again I got to see this one
with my partner Liz and it has what
honestly maybe the single sexiest
portrayal of a character I've ever seen
in a movie ever
the film is bound the character is of
all things named Corki and is played by
Gina Gershon and as far as I'm concerned
Gina Gershon takes the mantle of
smoldering rebellious sex from James
Dean in this film just standing there
just turning to look at violet who's
played by jennifer Tilly and the
contrast between them because one of
them is very femme one of them is very
butch but the connection between them
the intensity of it that there is a sex
scene in this thing holy crap and the
this is this is a neo-noir
effectively but the the way in which it
shot this is this was made by the
Wachowskis this was the movie they made
before the matrix and it it is shot
gorgeously it's ambitiously handled it
deals with awesome new art tropes it
plays with gender it plays with
expectations it plays with the machismo
and all of that and it's just so hot
like so many movies that try to be sexy
end up just being exploitative I just
sat there watching this and going I
don't feel too
for feeling turned on by this and that
is the mark of something that is sexy
without being exploitative this all if
you have not seen bound and you're up
for a very r-rated movie go see bound oh
yeah that's my that's my favorite
at present lgbtq+ themed movie what are
some of your favorites cuz honestly I
could use some more suggestions like I
said I I need and and honestly it's kind
of at this point easier to find in TV
but if you've got film suggestions cuz I
tied the amount of time I have it's hard
for me to get into new shows these days
but whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links patreon is down there if
you want to support what I do and and
all of that there's other links down
there besides including the book I wrote
about my own experience that's a
gender-fluid person I'll put a link to
my other channel veer a while down there
and there'll be other links besides to
check out merch and all this stuff don't
give it a look or don't you don't have
to if you do if you don't want to
because at the end of the day you are
the council
I'm just running the meanings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]